accident monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la préparation de la rentrée
scolaire suscite incompréhension et
colère dans nos territoires ruraux nous
vous avons déjà interrogé et nous avons
bien compris que votre matière favorite
était les mathématiques la référence au
ratio plutôt que les humanités le
département du Cantal n'échappe pas à
cette règle Gignac la bescherette sans
sacs instantanes inconstances
mené Valette Saint-Martin valmeroux et
de l'éternne Muraz Saint-Flour sur les
victimes de l'année avec cette même
logique inacceptable beaucoup d'autres
suivront cette année nous sommes en plus
victime d'un marché de dupes qui
consiste à accroître les moyens de votre
ministère vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
le ministre de 6,5% malgré prise sur les
territoires les investissements réalisa
bien qu'on augmente les vôtres ne le
faites pas au détriment des
qu'on augmente les vôtres ne le faites
pas au détriment d’exemple c'est
seulement 670 enseignants du premier
degré sur 780 qui sont devant élève soit
ratio de 80 administratifs
monsieur le ministre pensez-vous
améliorer ce ratio en remettant des
enseignants devant nos élèves des
classes rurales pour ne pas envoyer un
signal mortifère à nos petites écoles
qui sont la vie de nos communes je vous